[Musique]
ans
la première guerre mondiale a bouleversé
les sociétés 80 millions de soldats à
nourrir jour après jour
hop une armée n'a jamais été confrontés
à un tel défi plus de 500 millions de
civils indispensable un effort de guerre
à ravitailler
malgré les pénuries une nouvelle façon
de faire la guerre plus meurtrière est
né dans les tranchées mais ce conflit a
aussi révolutionné notre alimentation
la nourriture est un enjeu essentiel de
cette guerre totale
couper les vivres de l'ennemi tenir
quelques jours de plus que lui
la victoire est à ce prix
la fin sera une des grandes responsables
de l'effondrement de l'empiré allemand
et de ses alliés
[Musique]
en août 1914 de part et d'autre des
frontières le panier de victuailles le
pain le vin en duo soldats sont les
symboles communs d'un lien universel
ils sont aussi l'offrande reçu par celui
qui par donner son sang pour la patrie
les chemins qui mènent au front jusqu'au
sacrifice du soldat sont jalonnées de
ces dons gérard soyez 126ème régiment
d'infanterie nous sommes reçus à bras
ouverts les bonnes femmes du village
arrive avec des hautes plaines de
tartines de fruits et des sauts de café
au lait dans toutes les maisons
on m'offre à déjeuner
on partage la nourriture avec ses alliés
mais par patriotisme
on refuse de consommer celle de l'ennemi
partout les commerces alimentaires aux
consonances ennemis attise la colère de
la foule à paris le salon de thé à peine
rod est saccagé la société laitière
magie attaqué son lait pourrait être
empoisonnée
bien que suisse est neutre elles
financeraient l'allemagne quant à son
produit phare le bouillon cube
il est lui aussi visé les préfets vont
même jusqu'à ordonner par télégramme le
retrait de toutes ces plaques
publicitaires elles dissimulerait des
messages codés à l'intention de l'ennemi
[Musique]
les hommes déferle sur tous les fronts
ils laissent derrière eux des pays en
pleine mutation qui se sont
industrialisés en abandonnant des pans
entiers de leur agriculture
pour nourrir leur population
la grande bretagne la belgique
l'allemagne doivent s'approvisionner
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
les allemands particulier dépendre des
importations alimentaires plus d'un
quart de leurs denrées sont achetées à
l'étranger
au début les britanniques impose un
blocus qui réduit drastiquement les
entrées de nourriture et d'engrais
venant du chien les autres belligérants
arrête tout commerce avec l'asnl
elle est en particulier privées du blé
et plus tard du blé américain
indispensable à la production de pain
[Musique]
quant à la russie et à l' empire ottoman
soumis à des disettes chronique
il ne mesure pas encore les conséquences
de ne rentrer en guerre dès 1915 affamés
l'ennemi devient une stratégie
prioritaire
les deux camps renforcent leur blocus
naval les convois de vivres sont coulés
[Musique]
les états majors s'étaient préparés à
une guerre courte mais le conflit
s'enlise dans le monde entier des
soldats sont mobilisés les alliés
recrutent les hommes de leur colonie de
leurs comptoirs
comme ces bases du tos peuples bantous
sous domination anglaise
les sénégalais les nord-africains et
tant d'autres cent quarante mille
chinois sont engagés comme manoeuvre
[Musique]
mais
les états monte en puissance pour
fournir les denrées indispensables
ils interviennent dans l'économie à une
échelle inconnue jusqu alors dans chaque
pays
les gouvernement réquisitionne les
produits de première nécessité contrôler
les prix encadre la distribution le
pouvoir militaire allemand lui
ponctionne tout pour ravitailler en
priorité les soldats dès le début le
pouvoir militaire accapare toutes les
ressources du pays pour l'effort de
guerre
cela veut dire que les animaux de trait
compris dans les fermes les engrais
destinés à l'agriculture sont détournées
pour les munitions
dès septembre octobre 1914 il ya une
pénurie importante des produits de base
le pas les pommes de terre tout ce qui
touche les plus pauvres est
particulièrement longs que leurs balcons
pour cultiver
en france les armes et passe de
gigantesques marchés auprès des sociétés
agroalimentaires pour les viticulteurs
du languedoc
désireux de participer à l'effort de
guerre c'est aussi une opportunité
exceptionnelle pour écouler leur
production
les manufactures alimentaire prospère
saupiquet casgrain bonduelle lustucru
[Musique]
le marché de la conserve est une aubaine
pour des entreprises comme celle de jean
hénaff un breton qui propose de
nouvelles recettes de pâtes et pour
économiser le lait on valorise un
fromage peu connu le camembert dont la
production ne nécessite que deux litres
de lait par fromage sa notoriété fait il
est plus rapide à fabriquer que les
mental que l'armée avait adopté
auparavant
les commandes passées par l'armée sont
énormes et reviennent surtout aux plus
grandes entreprises
certaines font des bénéfices
considérables des négociants en farine
sont rappelés à l'ordre
il profite trop de la situation la
société la morue française est cool du
poisson avarié nettoyer à l'acide
ces abus lui valent d'être poursuivi par
l'administration
le jeu des alliances militaires
la réorganisation des marchés
alimentaires mondiaux modifie l'ordre
économique international
ce sont désormais des millions de tonnes
de marchandises qui circulent depuis les
etats-unis la nouvelle-zélande
l'australie l'argentine l'espagne le
canada
[Musique]
la france et la grande bretagne peuvent
s'appuyer sur leurs colonies auparavant
débouchés pour les produits européens
elles fournissent maintenant des denrées
indispensables à la victoire
[Musique]
les régions occupées sont pillées les
russes accaparent les denrées de galicie
les autrichiens celle de la roumanie la
belgique envahi dès l'été 1914 est
soumise aux pillages et aux réquisitions
il ya les allemands
j'ai imposé et qui impose un régime tout
à fait dingue et divise le pays dans des
hommes il ya aucun commerce entre les
deux zones qu on autorise ça veut dire
qu'il ya un village où il ya l'abondance
et à côté y'a rien ça mène à une famine
organisée
les belges doivent livrer une partie de
leur bétail le blocus les isole aussi
leurs ressources de leur garantissent
qu'un quart de leurs besoins
alimentaires
les affiches dénonce le calvaire de la
pauvre belgique menacée par la famine
[Musique]
face à cette mobilisation inédite
l'allemagne accepte que les pays neutres
interviennent dans le cadre de la
commisssion for release in belgium
[Musique]
des soupes populaires subviennent aux
besoins des plus pauvres des enfants
on les bourgeois et les classes moyennes
victimes elles aussi des pénuries
on évite la honte de la mendicité en
créant des restaurants économique
on voit très bien des gens qui s'étale
juillet pour aller dîner on voit le gars
sont debout comme avant la guerre ces
gens ils sont une erreur puis on sait
pas ce qu'on a le dépouillement du menu
que ces gens là ils vont ils vont manger
c'est sobre comme tout mais c'est un
menu avec un potage le nen potache qui
était d'y trouver aux pauvres mais de la
viande et des pommes de terre et un
verre de bière et un café 11 novembre
l'idée du restera économique disparaît
les gens n'ont roulé plus pas la
commission forêt leaf approvisionne
aussi le département du nord de la
france occupée par l'armée allemande
9 millions de françaises et de belges
évite ainsi la famine mais souffrent de
la faim avec le prolongement du conflit
tous les pays doivent rationaliser le
ravitaillement
arrivé dans les ports des millions de
tonnes de vivres sont acheminés
jusqu'aux populations civiles et en
combattant viande légumes pain conserve
foin sont transportés par tous les
moyens possibles
les autobus parisiens sont aménagés
spécialement pour le transport de la
viande leur carrosserie s'orne d'un
dessin de benjamin rabier un
illustrateur célèbre c'est une vache qui
rit
ces unités l'ont adoptée pour se moquer
des divinités guerrière germanique
célébré par richard wagner dans son
opéra la chevauchée des walkyries la
viande peut arriver congelés d'argentine
mais au front il est bien difficile de
respecter la chaîne du froid
lucien durosoir un musicien mobilisés
écrit en 1916 la viande j'évite d'en
manger
le poilu reçoit de la viande avariée
c'est incroyable de constater qu'à
l'imprévoyance président à ces
distributions des voitures frigo devrait
arriver jusqu'à nos cuisines mais cela
ne se passe pas ainsi
[Musique]
en effet au front même après plusieurs
mois de guerre beaucoup reste à
organiser
on va leur donner une cervelle hier à
une petite calotte métallique fait dans
l'urgence ces soldats vont dire bayrou
nous on nous donne ça pour nous mettre
cela sur la tête ça nous protège de rien
du tout si ce n'est que des retombées de
pierre on est content et projectiles
s'étaient totalement inefficace
le soldat qui avait reçu sept servane
hier qu'il a pratiqué des perforations
au fond de la salle manière sûrement
pour s'en servir comme égouttoir
l'intendance française fournit aux
soldats une cuillère et une fourchette
qui sont parfois estampillés au
matricule du soldat par contre chaque
soldat dispose d'un couteau mais d'un
couteau personnel un petit couteau de
poche et bien entendu suivant les
origines d'un cela les couteaux sont
différents à les corses et auvergnats
certains ont des laguiole les bretons
béton et couteaux de pêcheurs dès le
début du conflit le soldat allemand
n'est pas exposé au dénuement matériel
comme l'est le français
[Musique]
l'armée allemande dote ses soldats de
petit ustensile pratique adaptable sur
le terrain du style découvert clients
ces substances il préfigure aussi
l'activité touristique qui va apparaître
après la grande guerre c'est-à-dire le
camping
au fil de la guerre les armes et
améliore l'approvisionnement du front
d'immenses entrepôts sont créés pour
stocker les vivres en 1918 les
américains crée de toutes pièces des
installations gigantesques dans le loir
et cher
sur une surface de 30 kilomètres carrés
l'équivalent d'une ville comme toulouse
mais en logistique est sans rivale plus
de 6500 tonnes de viandes sont conservés
dans l'un des entrepôts frigorifiques
les plus modernes du monde
chaque jour le ravitaillement de 2
millions d'américains part de ses
entrepôts vers le front
[Musique]
l'armée en s'appuyant sur des études
médicales a défini un régime alimentaire
particulier pour les soldats la ration
de base prévoit 4000 calories par jour
avec pour ordinaire de la soupe du pain
du riz et des patates et jusqu'à 500 g
de viande par jour c'est énorme pour
l'époque
dans chaque arme et les rations s'adapte
aux habitudes alimentaires des peuples
surtout elle respecte les traditions
religieuses et culturelles des troupes
coloniales
c'est un atout pour la discipline et le
moral des peuples
pas de boeuf pour les indiens de l'armée
britannique pas de port pour les
musulmans
les nord africains goûte avec plaisir
les premiers essais de couscous en boîte
le soldat avait lui déjà il va avoir une
nouvelle éducation alimentaire qui va
arriver sur le front certains vont
découvrir pour la première fois des
boîtes de conserve en 1914 ça coûte très
cher à ce n'est que la haute société qui
consomme de la concerne et donc il sait
même pas ouvrir la boîte et comment la
faire cuire à et comment la préparer
mais la conserve qui s'impose aux
soldats n'est pas du goût de tous qui
découvre un contenu infâme du boeuf en
boîte auquel il donne le nom de bouli
beef ou de singe 5 cuistot délivrez nous
du singe interpelle le poilu le singe
désigne désormais la viande dans l'argot
du soldat la nourriture aspire tout une
langue imagée qui évoque son quotidien
le saindoux c'est le caporal la marmite
un obus allemands les anglais appellent
avec humour les boules de mortier tirés
sur l'ennemi
les plum pudding
[Musique]
quand les soldats se plaignent trop des
rations l'état-major réagi il se lance
dans des opérations de communication
comme des concours de cuistot filmé à
satiété
ces initiatives servent aussi à rassurer
les familles des camions bazar et des
coopératives militaires sont mises en
place à partir de 1915 pour améliorer un
peu le quotidien du soldat avec des
produits à prix fixes qui ne sont pas
servis par l'armée un moyen de contrer
l'inflation des prix et les profiteurs
qui abusent de la situation au front
l'eau est chaude au tournant tout au
long de la guerre léon brunet 1 à verdun
en 1916
je n'ai jamais tant souffert de la soif
il faut dire que moi les copains on
avait vu de notre urine avec un peu de
sucre sucer les racines d'arbres sucer
le juste à l'est d'une boîte de conserve
abandonnés par les [__] sur le front
l'eau est rare lots de qualité est
introuvable de boire n'importe quelle
eau forcément exposé les hommes
attrapent et la dysenterie voir des
fièvres typhoïdes donc il faut créer des
réserves d'eau des citernes et les
acheminer il ya une organisation de sur
la consommation de l'eau qui est
beaucoup plus élaborée du côté allemand
chez l'adversaire en face où là on va
drainer l'eau et on va offrir aux
combattants les premières au minéral lui
ai donc l'eau minérale existait déjà
dans la société allemande d'avant 1914
étaient consommés chaque soldat allemand
lorsqu il le désirera au ras de l'eau
minérale alors que chez les français
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
le seul là le plus débrouillard va
essayer d'avoir plusieurs bidons avec
lui on voit que le soldat a voulu en
augmenter la contenance
il ya un peu plus bombée que les bidons
qui n'a pas été transformé la vie d une
cartouche et il a introduit le canon
dans le goulot et le souffle de la
combustion du départ du coup bien
entendu donne un donà choc à l'intérieur
du bidon et le gonfle davantage pour
gagner quelques centimes supplémentaires
qui lui ont peut-être sauvé la vie mais
heureusement pour le poilu le vent est
une excellente manière de rendre l'eau
potable
il fait partie de la ration des soldats
français
un quart de litre en 1914 un litre en
c'est un vin qui titre 8° bien moins que
nos vins actuel qui monte à 12 ou 13
degrés le soldat enivrait pour monter à
l'assaut reste un mythe un cliché bien
entretenu on sert au contraire beaucoup
de vin après les combats comme
récompense
le vin est profondément ancré dans
l'iconographie est dans l'imaginaire de
toute la nation
en france le vin c'est une culture et
des chansons en gare de châlons sur
marne une statue est érigée au dieu
pinard
à quoi lui bacchus où les plaisirs de la
vie si le vin est glorifié a contrario
la consommation d'alcool fort et
combattu l'absinthe est interdite grande
victoire des ligues antialcooliques qui
voient diminuer la consommation d'alcool
parmi les civils
[Musique]
l'armée française ces kits de cuisine
roulante en 1915 avec retard des
allemands les russes les japonais en
avait eu depuis le début de la guerre
les roulante permettent d'apporter des
repas chauds aux soldats ils n'ont plus
à préparer leur dîner un service
essentiel se rapproche du combattant et
améliore le moral une roulante par
compagnie de 200 hommes apportent à
quelques kilomètres du front les marmite
de soupe de riz et de café ici les
soldats de corvée viennent se
ravitailler pour acheminer la nourriture
dans les tranchées en ce début de xxème
siècle avec la soupe le pain reste la
base de l'alimentation populaires et
rurales
jusqu'à 800 grammes par jour pour un
soldat français
[Musique]
les américains eux ont déjà leur
incontournable pain de mie en tranches
[Musique]
les indiens confectionnent leurs propres
galettes de pain l'etg a pâti avec une
fine complète
le hatha que l'armée anglaise importe
spécialement d'inde
quand la qualité du pain baisse sur le
front comme à l'arrière on doute de la
capacité du commandement a gagné la
guerre l'état des prisonniers allemands
renseigne sur la situation alimentaire
au sein de l'armée impériale leur pain
est révélateur de la grave pénurie qui
touche le pays
très tôt l'armée accaparent les stocks
de céréales et de farine dès 1915 à
berlin on impose des cartes de
rationnement de pain
le pain allemand est composé de pommes
de terre dessus ou de sang animal ce
pain de guerre en allemand le krx
kartoffel brottes est surnommé le pain
kaka il donne lieu à de nombreuses
plaisanteries chez les alliés les
allemands s'habitue à voir les affiches
du gouvernement sur les murs et sur les
kiosques au point de la liste des
dernières mesures
ce dont on va encore les prix le pouvoir
militaire réquisitionne tous les
combustibles la santé de la population
décline considérablement à cause du
manque de vivres et de l'impossibilité
de se chauffer ou de cuire la nourriture
les gens sont vulnérables et la
mortalité augmente à cause de maladies
liées à la famine des millions de
personnes tombent malades après avoir
mangé des produits de substitution
les fameuses ersatz on vend des cendres
à la place du sel de la sciure de bois à
la place de la farine
les enfants sont nourris avec un lait
très diluée pendant que leurs mères
doivent travailler dans les usines de
guerre non j'ai des rutabagas pour les
allemands c'était une grande insulte
c'était de la nourriture pour les
animaux pas pour les allemands
[Musique]
offrons à la mort omniprésente s'ajoute
la fin les hommes de corvée se faufile
dans les tranchées lors de dangereuses à
des retours entre les roulante et le
front jean giono mobilisés écrit depuis
huit jours les corvées de soupe ne
reviennent plus elles partent le soir à
la nuit noire et c'est fini elles
fondent comme du sucre dans du café pas
un homme n'est retourné quand le pain
arrive il est souvent mouiller les
rations froide ou souillée de terre
isolée dans un trou d'obus
le soldat comme à verdun ne peut compter
que sur ses vivres de réserve des
concerts du biscuit de guerre et son
bidon d'eau
on voit là bas un mort couché par terre
pour y ait plein de mouches mais encore
ceinture et de bidons et de boules de
pain passé dans un fil de fer
on attend que le bombardement se calme
on rampe jusqu'à lui on détache de son
corps les boules de pain on prend les
bidons pleins d'autres bidons ont été
trouvés par les balles le pain est mou
il faut seulement coupé le morpho qui
touchait le corps voilà ce qu'ont fait
tous le jours cela dure depuis 25 jours
[Musique]
les mêmes mots ont pu être dit dans la
tranchée d'en face plus à l'est en
orient en irak d'autres souffrances
frappe les soldats indiens de l'armée
britannique
1916 à kout al amara à 160 km de bagdad
face à l'armée ottomane les troupes
britanniques et leurs régiments indiens
sont coupés de leurs bases arrières ils
survivent avec très peu des conserves et
des biscuits de guerre mais la famine
annihile finalement toute résistance
il faut déposer des armes un capitaine
indien témoigne le drapeau turc floch
sur la ville à cause de la famine
notre général a dû se rendre en six mois
onze mille soldats indiens épuisé par
les privations sont victimes du scorbut
plus à l'ouest au nord de la grèce dans
la région de salonique se jouent
d'autres épreuves pour les soldats
britanniques et français retranché
depuis des mois face aux bulgares les
maladies dysenterie et paludisme font
des ravages
ici l'approvisionnement est sans cesse
menacé par la guerre maritime pour
survivre et éviter le scorbut les
soldats cultive des potagers sur 1500
hectares
[Applaudissements]
à paris clemenceau opposée à l'envoi des
troupes françaises en grèce les traites
par dérision de jardiniers de salonique
[Applaudissements]
en
face à la mort la vie s'expriment dans
les moments de convivialité la musique
du phonographe répondent aux tirs du
cani
la table réunit les camarades avec
lesquels on a tissé des liens forts dans
les tranchées
[Musique]
loin de sa famille le soldat partagent
ces colis avec le copain venu le sauver
sous la mitraille
on fait tourner un pâté la gnôle du
grand-père ou la cancoillotte en gros
toise
on se recueille
on découvre les traditions culinaires
d'autres régions d'autres contrées et
lors des fêtes on cuisine parfois de
véritables festins
pour la fête traditionnelle de
thanksgiving ces américains ont même
réussi à dénicher des demandes
[Musique]
et puis il ya les permissions le soldat
rêve de s'en mettre plein la porte
alger les rations les à l'arrière il lui
semble qu'il compte bien peu
dans le pépère un journal du front on
n'est pas tendre avec les civils ces
privilégiés
voyez les cafés les cafés sont pleins
les trottoirs sont noires de monde et
pour qu'on prenne garde un mutilé
il faut qu'ils le souhaitent croyab le
mans et oui on s'est habitué à la guerre
[Musique]
où
et
car à l'arrière dans les pays en guerre
les prix montent la situation
alimentaire s'aggrave de jour en jour
les villes sont les plus durement
touchés par le manque de charbon de pain
de sucre de légumes 9 et de viande
les gouvernements fixent des prix
maximums pour les denrées de première
nécessité
en france la carte de rationnement de
pain est introduite en 1917 le boulanger
doit maintenant vendre du pain rassis
on n'en mangera - il réclame une
compensation car il devait perdre deux
points dont deux prix de vente
[Musique]
interdiction de vendre aussi les
spécialités considéré comme trop
luxueuses
finie la brioche et la pâtisserie les
civils se plaignent de la cherté de la
vie
il découvre l'inflation presque inconnu
jusqu alors
même en grande bretagne le lait vient à
manquer en pleine guerre
les mères et les bébés manifestent lé
pénurie touche jusqu'aux pommes de terre
les files d'attentes s'allongent
dans tous les pays les populations sont
mobilisés pour l'effort de guerre pour
les soldats il faut se restreindre
économiser des campagnes d'affichage
paraissent dans tous les pays
l'italie a besoin de viande blé graisses
sucres manger moins de viande pour
ménager notre cheptel économiser le blé
pour les femmes de france
ne gâchez pas le pain le pain de la
nation la nourriture gagnera la guerre
ne gâche rien
l'union sacrée passe par les assiettes
la victoire est à ce prix elle passe par
des sacrifices dont rendre compte les
nouvelles éditions des livres de
recettes ménagères de tous les pays
devenaient des professionnels de
l'économie domestique de guerre il ya un
propos des éditeurs et des auteurs là
dessus achetez mon livre parce que plus
à l'est réussir à cuisiner sans viande
sans farine sans sucre en évitant de
faire la queue dans les magasins en
évitant de perdre du combustible donc on
va aller vers la cuisine avec des
plantes sauvages la cuisine avec les
restes la cuisine avec de nouveaux
aliments pourquoi pas on manque de
farine on va mettre la pomme de terre
dans son gâteau mais aussi ce que
l'auteur appelle les petits secrets
comme enlever le goût d'orange dollars
enlever le goût de moisi aux haricots et
fèves démarrer enlever le goût sucré aux
pattes hadj les enlever le goût rance au
beurre de conserves enlever le goût de
boîtes aux conserves de légumes enlevé à
la viande de bouc son odeur repoussante
on voit apparaître la propagande qui
s'adresse aux femmes et aux enfants afin
qu'il prenne part au conflit et qu'ils
économisent et que par leur comportement
ils participent pas à l'effort de guerre
[Musique]
les enfants doivent montrer l'exemple et
participer à leur manière à la
mobilisation générale
on quitte la classe pour planter des
pommes de terre récolter des fruits
sauvages cultiver la moindre parcelle
abandonné
leur et aux crèches et aux cantines
scolaires car les maires sont dans les
usines de guerre les femmes travaillent
dans l'armée du foyer 17 affiche
allemande
elle remplace aussi les hommes dans les
travaux de force à la campagne elle
laboure elle sème à elle fauche elle
s'occupe du bétail
elles sont nourries ce pour les bébés
orphelins ou dont les mères sont à l'
usine en grande bretagne elles défilent
dans les villes pour encourager la
population à rejoindre l'armée des
paysannes
les soldats travaillent d'auchan non
loin du front
cependant les difficultés
d'approvisionnement demeure et l'on râle
contre ceux qui profitent de la
situation
s'engraissent sur le dos des soldats
profitent de la misère des gens la
grogne monte en particulier dans les
villes de garnison américaine où les
prix deviennent inabordables pour la
population ces profiteurs du petit
marchand aux gros industriels
on les nomme les mercantis sait rien
chéreau oui mais moi je ris que tous les
jours ma vie ici
courage à ce quart après la guerre on
l'aura d'autres limousine ils sont
épatants voilà treize mois que je leur
revente 3 francs du 20 12 sous elles ne
pensent même pas me casser la gueule
dans les pays alliés la distribution de
vivres est sous contrôle
un film de propagande sur les halles de
paris témoigne aussi d'une réalité en
france
les pénuries reste limitée le niveau de
vie va jusqu'à augmenté en grande
bretagne grâce aux salaires élevés et à
l'efficacité du ravitaillement dans ces
pays démocratique
les gouvernements ont choisi de ne pas
sacrifier la population civile ou
militaire
au contraire les empires allemand
austro-hongrois et ottoman approvisionne
les soldats au détriment de leur
population de leurs sujets en allemagne
la disette et la misère s'installe
durablement les tensions s'intensifient
lors du terrible hiver 1916 1917
on se nourrit de rave dans les villes
allemandes et autrichiennes
c'est l'hiver des navets de sinistre
mémoire
les affiches incite à tout économiser
collecter les noyaux de fruits pour en
extraire de l'huile récupérer les
épluchures de pommes de terre et de
légumes femmes et filles
apportez vos cheveux donnez vos peaux de
lapins l'armée de terre en a besoin
mais le blocus et toof l'allemagne en
1918 la ration quotidienne tombe à moins
de 1000 calories
le tiers des besoins d'un adulte il ya
de grandes passions dans les rues il ya
ce sentiment que des ennemis intérieurs
comme les ennemis sur le champ de
bataille et c'est de vaincre l'allemagne
en la fin alors qu'avant la guerre des
principales divisions de la société
les divisions socio-économiques se
situer au niveau de la production c'est
à dire les ouvriers d'un côté et les
patrons d'industrie de l'autre désormais
ce qui divise la population c'est la
consommation ceux qui ont accès à la
nourriture et ceux qui en sont privés
paysan fais ton devoir les villes ont
faim ces affiches placardées dans les
campagnes rendent compte des tensions
qui s'exacerbe entre les ruraux et les
citadins berlin puis vienne prague dans
l' empire austro-hongrois le quotidien
de la population se dégrade d'année en
année
population même temps la population
rurale en particulier les paysans a
accès à la terre fait peut trouver sur
place assez de nourriture alors que de
nombreux citadins n'ont aucun accès à la
terre pour les ouvriers les paysans sont
égoïstes fussent ils ne livrent pas
leurs produits sur le marché officiel
rationnés mais au marché noir
je ne peuvent avoir de meilleurs prix et
donc du point de vue des ouvriers les
paysans sont responsables de
l'aggravation de la situation
alimentaire puis rapidement des côtes
pareil les gens riches peuvent acheter
de la nourriture marché noir bien sûr
mais ils sont dans une situation que les
pauvres doivent aller à la campagne pour
échanger leurs biens une bague en or
contre un morceau de viande par exemple
ou même voler de la nourriture est donc
la criminalité augmente pendant la
guerre à cause de la pauvreté la
population vivent sous ce titre sorti ça
coince en allemagne les conséquences de
la fin sont terribles la guerre a
énormément diviser la population
développer les soupçons l'hostilité
entre les allemands ces tensions ont
vraiment dur et c'est une des racines de
l'antisémitisme qui se développe alors à
cause du succès économique de certains
tout cela est dans une certaine mesure
encouragée par les autorités qui pendant
la guerre répandent l'idée que les juifs
accapare la nourriture
dans l' empire ottoman
le gouvernement turc met en oeuvre un
plan d'extermination totale des
populations non musulmanes
à partir de 1915 les arméniens sont
méthodiquement déportés et exterminés
ces images témoignent des massacres de
masse des tortures des viols commis lors
du programme de destruction
[Musique]
le génocide provoque la mort de près
d'un million et demi d'arméniens la
privation d'eau et de nourriture lors
des marches de la mort dans le désert ou
dans les camps de concentration tient
aussi une place centrale dans le
génocide contre les arméniens
la famine est intentionnel
[Musique]
d'autres régions de l' empire ottoman
sont prises dans l'étau du blocus
maritime britannique et d'un blocus
terrestre décidées par le gouverneur
ottoman
[Musique]
au liban entre 1915 et 1918 une famine
emporte deux cent mille personnes un
tiers de la population
[Musique]
c'est rare photographie prise en secret
par ibrahim noun canam directeur de
l'assistance dit sa volonté de témoigner
d'une situation terrible ans
[Musique]
dès 1917 en allemagne en autriche en
russie les privations les famines
provoque des émeutes des révolte le
marché noir qui est parlée les alliés
prend des proportions énormes
la crise alimentaire joue un rôle
essentiel dans la dissolution de
l'empiré austro hongrois
car les problèmes liés à la nourriture
deviennent si important qu'il ya
beaucoup de tensions entre les
différentes parties n'empire entre les
villes entre les classes sociales les
paysans et les ouvriers la société
totalement divisé les gens s'opposent
les uns aux autres le sentiment
d'appartenir à une communauté s'effondre
et aussi le respect de l'ordre public
les gens attendaient de l'état qu'ils
organisent un ravitaillement efficace
mais de ce point de vue l'état échoue et
il perd toute légitimité aux yeux de la
population
les dirigeants des puissances centrales
sont discrédités aux yeux de leurs
populations
avant même d'avoir perdu la guerre sur
les champs de bataille
en allemagne la révolution de novembre
1918 signe la fin de l' empire et
accompagne la défaite militaire
[Musique]
11 novembre 1918 dans les pays
vainqueurs
la foule fait l'armistice mais la fin
des combats n'a pas d'impact immédiat
sur la situation alimentaire
même chez les alliés vainqueurs de la
guerre les pénuries et le rationnement
s'éternise dans les grands empires qui
ont éclaté en allemagne en autriche
hongrie en russie la situation est
catastrophique
les puissances vaincus sont maintenus
sous pression par le blocus alliés qui
dure jusqu'au traité de paix de 1919 750
mille civils allemands meurt des suites
de la sous-alimentation pendant et après
la guerre
[Musique]
dans la russie révolutionnaire la famine
fait un million de victimes entre 1921
et 1922
[Musique]
des générations entières sont marqués
par les privations
elle porte les séquelles de la famine
tuberculose rachitisme
les hôpitaux aux autrichiens et
allemands accueille les enfants des
formes et dans ces pays
cette génération aura une taille
inférieure à la normale
[Musique]
des territoires entiers sont dévastés
polluer en france comme en allemagne
on offre des prothèses aux soldats des
paysans qui retrouvent leurs terres des
prothèses dérisoire pour les travaux de
force
[Musique]
les etats-unis sortis de leur isolation
nisme deviennent des acteurs
incontournables de l'économie mondiale
ils sont les principaux bénéficiaires de
ce conflit dès 1917 lors d'une interview
un homme d'affaires américain se
féliciter de la bonne marche des
affaires
la grande guerre a quintuplé le chiffre
dans nos affaires décupler nos bénéfices
et tout ce trafic magnifique nous
l'avons opéré avec les alliés nous nous
sommes enrichis en vous procurant du
coton la viande
les obus du blé des mitrailleuses des
chevaux des automobiles tout ce qu'on
pouvait vous vendre nous vous l'avons
vendu notre stock
or dépasse aujourd'hui le sto corps de
tous les alliés réunis cet argent que
nous avons gagnés sur vous nous vous le
prêteront la grande guerre
l'espoir d'une expansion économique
nouvelle
[Musique]
un nouvel ordre commercial et
agroalimentaire s'impose durablement au
monde on a découvert de nouveaux
produits qui traversent les océans de
nouvelles façons de s'alimenter et dans
l'europe en état de siège
la première guerre mondiale a montré que
la fin est une arme redoutable
[Musique]
non